au début des années 90 la yougoslavie se
disloque aujourd'hui avec la fin du
communisme la yougoslavie vient
d'imploser sous nos yeux et les
différentes républiques qui la composent
et se déclare une à une indépendant
après la slovénie la croatie c'est au
tour de la bosnie herzégovine en mars
1992 le pays votre pour son indépendance
mais les serbes ne l'entendent pas de
cette oreille aujourd'hui des premiers
coups de feu ont été tirés à sarajevo
affrontements sanglants dans la capitale
la nuit dernière entre serbes opposés à
cette indépendance d'un côté musulman et
croate de l'autre pour calmer les
tensions une rencontre au sommet a lieu
entre le président bosniaque un musulman
et le chef du parti autonomiste servent
les deux camps appellent la population à
abandonner les barricades aujourd'hui la
bosnie herzégovine paraît donc apaiser
mais le calme reste précaire un calme
plus que précaire puisque quelques
semaines plus tard le 5 avril 1992 les
combats reprennent on assiste en croatie
en bosnie herzégovine à une
recrudescence des combats et de la
violence qu'on se bat même dans les
cimetières
responsable de cette nouvelle violation
du cessez-le-feu selon les croates et
les bosniaques l'armée fédérale et les
milices serbes au même moment les 5 et 6
avril 1992 les bosniaques d sont dans la
rue et manifestent pour la paix trente
mille personnes rassemblées au péril de
leur vie sur la grande avenue qui sépare
le parlement de l'hôtel holiday inn
devenue le quartier général des serbes
hostiles à l'indépendance de la bosnie
herzégovine et comme hier en début
d'après-midi des extrémistes serbes
postés sur le toit de l'hôtel ouvre le
feu sur la foule les premiers mots
retombe et à partir du 6 avril 1992
c'est le début du siège les combattants
serbes en cercle la capitale bosniaque
pilonnent la ville du haut des montagnes
qui entourent sarajevo
les combats ont repris de plus belle ce
matin en plein centre ville autour du
parlement et de l'aéroport le quartier
général de la force des nations unies a
également été la cible de tirs d'armes
automatiques et les habitants sont
prises au piège pendant près de quatre
ans jusqu'en février 1996 ils vont vivre
au rythme des tirs serbe tirer des
collines surplombant la ville trois obus
de mortier viennent de s'abattre sur la
population ils ont touché leurs cibles
avec précision pour tuer des civils et
maintenir ce climat de terreur et
d'insécurité en bosnie un climat de
terreur et un bilan le siège de sarajevo
a fait près de 12 mille victimes
[Musique]